welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in Thor the dark world might be
best remembered as the event that a
future fatter version of its hero
drunkenly stumbles back to in recaps to
perfection
the dark elves scary being so Jane Yoshi
she stuck her hand inside a rock this
one time and and then the ephah stuck
itself inside her and she became very
very sick and so I had to take her to
house guard which is where I'm from and
we had to try and fix her ant-man was on
board and so was i I've had it at the
top of my totally sincere Marvel ranking
pin tweet for years
the dark world formally introduced the
Infinity stones to the MCU Albion sludge
form and set up later events like
Avengers in game and thor ragnarok and
easy to miss ways that this infinity
saga rewatch makes super rewarding ok
Thor the dark world opens with Odin's
history from the Year 2988 BC now an
Avengers endgame this date reef Lee
appeared on the time vortex monitor as a
destination year what and game never
showed anyone going back this far in
time but it indicates to us that the
adventures at least considered trying to
intercept the reality stone from its
origin point Thor the dark world had
many cooks rector Alan Taylor with this
prologue actually directed by future
deadpool director 10 miller the script
was written by christopher yost along
with Christopher Markus Stephen McFeely
the super team who wrote the biggest
Marvel installments Winter Soldier Civil
War infinity war an end game Eminem
wrote those last two in a sealed-off
conference room with the directors and
producers covering dry erase boards with
insane infinity stone timelines those
happy warriors solving that puzzle
mirrored the Avengers brainstorming in
endgame and Thor's homecoming to Asgard
and the time heist
I believe represents these riders
reconciling their choices in the dark
world it's a story about the cost of
mistakes Asgard is doomed curses are
resurrected smart towheads named Erik
with a K go ignored in the MCU will pay
leader the Dark Elves Malekith has a
scar reflecting his later conic
appearance but retains the chess played
star from his first appearance
Thor's grandfather Bor uses the Bifrost
notice the markings there to hide the
aether we first see Loki in Chains
after his adventures crimes now judged
by Odin
we'll end this story in the opposite
position Unchained in Odin's place on
the throne we are not gods we're born we
live we die just as humans do
it will take five thousand years five
thousand years is the amount of time
between convergences 2988 to the present
day and loki using this to mark the end
of their lifespans foretells the coming
Ragnarok and both the deaths of Odin and
Loki five thousand years after the
previous convergence adding the few
years on to that Thor battles alongside
lady SIF in the Warriors three Volstagg
Hogan and Fandral now recast as future
Shazam actor Zachary Levi in Hogan's
homeworld of vanaheim the script names
their foes as the Marauders also the
name of a mutant group in Marvel Comics
but these a-holes are obviously
different the production design that
said they included in the background
Chitauri soldiers and korbinite soldiers
the home race of beta ray bill Carbonite
soldiers are also the ones Gamora and
nebula were fighting an endgame notice
the movement of Mjolnir here
blasting from nowhere not conceived [ __ ]
and then rebound in midair to it's
worthy wielder this is the same exact
visual movement used in endgame with
millionnaire rebounds to its new worthy
wielder Thor and SIF check in completely
under control
this will be the rationale for uses at
the end of Ragnarok letting Asgard be
destroyed in a controlled sort of burn
Thor face is a big old Cronin which is
the same racist chord from Thor Ragnarok
this duel was gonna be a lot more
complicated but the writers brought in a
vendor's director Joss Whedon to rewrite
a bunch of scenes this was one of them
he shortened it into this great joke and
homage to the scene in Raiders of the
Lost Ark it was also kind of a
last-minute rewrite because Harrison
port head the ship's Thor returns to
Asgard with a Bifrost bridge repaired
after Thor severed it in the first movie
later in the film you can see the line
where Thor cracked it we follow the two
Ravens
Bobbo as Hugin munion Odin's Midgard
spies who snooped on Loki and Thor in
the Avengers and were visible on Odin's
throne and bedside in the first film
notice that throughout this movie Thor
has this braid with a dark strand of
hair wrapped around his own some spotted
this in age of Ultron you're like oh
it's Loki's hair and others were like no
it's Freitas hair but the fact that Thor
already has it here this early suggests
that it's James
poor girl is always getting stuffed
creepily taken from her at the feast
Volstagg calls back Thor's big line in
the first film and Thor recalls old
memories with sip
I remember you celebrated the Battle of
her again so much that you nearly
started the second well the first was so
much fun
Thor later stammers about this same
battle to his mom and in game
oh hi let's remember the Battle of
heroine when I got hit in the face with
the broadsword
Jamie Alexander didn't return as sit and
thor ragnarok but she didn't appear in
an episode of agents of shield she
seriously injured her back while
shooting this movie but only took a
month off to recover so yeah I'm with
the Odin Thor ditched the earth nerd
stick the SIF Darcy crashes Jane's date
and she butters bread which seems like
nothing but it does kind of recall the
odd word choice just used by Odin you
must think I'm a piece of bread that
needs to be buttoned so heavily
perhaps his Ravens were spying on this
date through those big windows and he's
annoyed to see his son with that earth
woman's hair wrapped up in his they show
Jane gravitational anomalies caused by
the convergence setting up the portal
Hoppe in finale no this is very
monochromatic except for a red tinted
window indicating the encroaching ether
on Jane
you know it's as if the reality stone
kind of like the mind stone possesses a
kind of cosmic intelligence that drives
it to be reunited with others Thor
brings Jane back to Asgard and notice
that the Bifrost hits the front of the
police car and that chunk comes back
with them through the Bifrost reawakened
Malekith in the Dark Elves return to
Vertov hime a name that literally
translates to home of the black elves in
Old Norse and Icelandic actually Iceland
was the shooting location here chosen
for its volcanic black soil free-cos
sources study Jane's infection that's a
quantum field generator isn't it it's a
solo food yet another example of the
recurring overlap between earth science
and Asgardian magic Odin gives us the
MCS first explanation of the Infinity
stones and notice that these stone
specific lines come in when Odin's face
is off screen now relics that predate
the universe itself the leader Malekith
made a weapon out of that darkness and
it was called the ether while the other
relics often appear as stones
ether is fluid and ever-changing it
changes matter into dark matter
everything reveals why the reality stone
in ether are so muddy in this movie
literally in the way they're written
clearly the original scene featured Oded
just explaining the lore of the ether
presumably based on the ether from
alchemy legend but then later the studio
must have been like well it'd be great
if this sludge could also be one of the
six stones that we're trying to
establish on cinematic universe let's
just get Anthony Hopkins dumped in some
of the new dialogue over this book to
merge the two ideas
Malekith transforms has made an
algorithm into curse another villain
from the Thor Comics actually his look
in this movie reflects both the
characters bull horns but he also has
lava look reflecting his fall into a
lava pit in the comics and frigate
visits Loki as we saw with the first
movie Thor 2 is once again really
Loki's story he frames the opening in
the closing images
he's victorious he goes through a lot
ragnaroks play reframes the events of
this movie with Loki as the hero but
endgame fixes all this and does so by
restaging this scene reassigning
free-cos emotional moment from Loki to
Thor Loki tosses up his cup it's a shot
that was later reused an in-game and
curse lights up Thor swoops in action
catching mill near midair and notice how
the moment he does his red cape
materializes so it's supposed to happen
every time he powers up with me on air
but this might be the only time they
ever see we see the Cape come out and
Bri watching it when he tried to align
the concurrent events of in-game there's
definitely an amazing Marvel one-shot
that's gotta be made showing the moment
that Thor steals meal near sticking it
up with a moment past Thor leaps off
this balcony with nothing to catch
Malekith kills Frigga and she gets a
proper Viking funeral so say had the
music here later gets reused for Loki's
play and for Ragnarok
[Music]
and her body fragments into glowing
particles that float upward presumably
to Valhalla since she did die honorably
in battle
but notice when Odin dies in Ragnarok
his particles go out to sea but we don't
really see them go up suggesting maybe a
less clear afterlife for this noble
leader but a guy who had a violent
violent past that wasn't necessarily so
honorable
indeed Thor challenges Odin on this
later his men move for 110 thousand a
scud in play and how many of our men
shall fall on there as many as our nigut
we will fight to the last house Guardian
breath the last top of us got in blood
and how are you different from Malekith
the difference my son is that I will win
and just for good measure
this is the warlord Odin spent most of
his life as the hidden history exposed
by hella and Ragnarok a past bathed and
Asgardian blood a notice with Thor here
Odin staggers just a bit another tell
that his Ragnarok death is imminent
meanwhile a Midgard dr. Erik Selvig my
hero gets institutionalized after
streaking through Stonehenge which to be
fair it is a very exciting place
remember selvig's madness is actually
divine insight gained from the mine
stone in the insanity on his blackboard
actually Hall refers to major details
that come about in Marvel's future like
ant-man listen to Thor story if I were
in this room playing Canasta with Stan
Lee I would be taking notes
buckle up nerds it's time for a joke
down at the center of the board is you
Tercel with the nine realms including
the devil ear which appears in infinity
war The Fault refers to a rift in Marvel
Comics that leads to the cancerverse
dimension a fault ripped open by Black
Bolt and Vulcan and stabilized by the
guardians of the galaxy the crossroads
is another Marvel dimension where Doctor
Strange exiled the Hulk the Nexus of all
realities is another gateway to other
worlds located in the Florida Everglades
and protected by Man Thing 6160 universe
is written a nod to earth-616 that's the
prime universe of the Marvel Comics the
MCU it's technically earth 1 9999 though
Mysterio lied to Peter Parker calling
this universe earth-616 and far from
home this is earth to mention 6 1 6 I'm
from
eight three three and six one six was
the number of Scott Lang storage unit an
in-game Simonson's theory of relativity
is a nod to both the Einstein theory of
relativity and Walt Simonson Thor comics
writer who actually cameoed in the first
film
Kyle Plus Yoast equals X is a nod to
comics writers Craig Kyle and
Christopher Yost Yasuko wrote this movie
they created the Wolverine legacy
character x-23 then there's the terminal
phase transition a concept that actually
came up in ant-man and the wasp with
characters like ghost with energy from
the quantum realm capable of phasing
through different states of matter and
on a quantum scale in different
realities simultaneously the kind of
theoretical physics that led to the
quantum realm allowing for alternate
timelines an end game there's also the
name Schrodinger and a cat drawing
referring of course to the famous
thought experiment of Schrodinger's cat
one of the first examples of multiverse
theory that inspired the multiverse of
the ensue now appears to be taking place
in Schrodinger's cat was both alive and
dead at the same time now we got
Schrodinger's loci look holed up here in
the blue dungeon it's hard to maintain
proper flexibility well thanks to our
sponsor footmouse introducing a
revolution in gaming footmouse the first
science-based gaming mouse made for feat
I'm playing with my hands my feet my
whole time body's foot mouse stick your
foot in the game just kidding are real
sponsor is rainshadow legends Rache I
know legends is the epic RPG with the
great battles and the even greater ads I
like building up my champions over time
and then having them beat up monsters
for me it's way better than having to
fight my own monsters the daily log and
awards program for new players has been
doubled to 180 days each day you can
claim your free rewards like energy
refills gems and a free barbarian
legendary champion skill of the drakes
and I guess her skill is a ab workouts
whoa I like going to the tavern in the
game and upgrading my champions you can
give them a little beard looking
upgrades or sacrifice lesser champions
to make them stronger so what are you
waiting for go to the video description
click on the special links and if you
are a new player you will get 100,000
silver and one free epic champion Joe
ton look at that big bearded barbarian
those rewards will be waiting for you in
the inner box here
good luck and I will see you there okay
so in Jane's nightmare her paws
Chimere the reality stone manifests into
these creepy black eyes a little detail
shared with past times the Infinity
stones took possession of someone door
in the team plots in treason what then
your lovely mortal is being guarded by a
legion of I know Yahoo will see you
coming from miles away in Norse
mythology Einherjar refers to these
souls of the dead in Valhalla here it's
the name of the city guard hind Allah
mentions secret nan Bifrost portals in
and out of Asgard known only to Loki
witched Loki actually bragged about to
him back in the first film do you think
the Bifrost is the only way and out of
this realm there are secret pause
between the worlds to which even you
with all your gifts are blind loki
lowers the illusions to show his true
grief over freakish death and upon
release plays with some more illusions
first as a soldier we later see him mask
himself with after faking its death in
returning before Odin and then he shifts
to a familiar face america's face much
better
costumes bit much so tighter with the
confidence they can feel the
righteousness surging hey wanna have a
rousing discussion about truth honor
patriotism God nice to pull this off
they first had Tom Hiddleston dress up
in cap suit and do an impression of
Chris Evans and then Evans watch that
impression and then did an impression of
that notice how the other identities
retained Thorin Loki's voices Bible the
cap we hear his voice on their way a de
Asgard Thor eclipsed a statue of Bohr
well done you just decapitated your
grandfather the comics lore actually
does kill Bohr at one point and then
they land in spargel time they trick
malakut by pretending to cut off Thor's
arm but Mallika's arm actually does get
cut off later
it's another instance of Kevin Peggy's
weird ode to star wars amputations and
every face to film roll that cliff
[Music]
look any requests for malkov a good seat
from which to watch as God but he
actually does get a front row seat to
Asgard's fiery end and Ragnarok Malekith
takes the ether from Jane and the battle
ends with the deaths of curse and Loki
but not really see you in Hell what stop
that Loki is saying HCL how the Norse
afterlife that I have suggested we might
see Loki resurrect from in four for
another clue that Loki isn't really dead
here he turns gray instead of his
natural blue frost giant skin Jane and
Thor e is a convergence willing to
return to Earth Thor hangs me linear on
the coat hanger coat hangers worthy it's
so vague uses ancient ruins to map out
the convergence coordinates for the
great constructions Mayans the Chinese
Egyptians they made use of the
gravitational effects of the conversions
and then this is a map Marvel's the
Eternals will be sent partially in these
ancient times with a folklore from each
of these cultures implied to be
connected to the eternal scraps the
Eternals were the ones who gave so big
this map to Paulo this leads to the
Greenwich battle with Malekith portal II
through various realms one of them shows
the volcanic surface of Muspelheim
Searchers realm and some say you can see
searchers for more is horned head or it
could be the psychological evolutionary
misperception called pareidolia which i
like to define musically as evolution
that's up family singing faces where
none exists the convergence also brings
them to Jotunheim home of the frost
giants from the first movie also
allowing for the return of frost beast
who shows up in the post-credits scene
Thor also tumbles into Charing Cross
station solid British word play there
for also having to mind the gap between
realms it's also a callback to the pun
in the first cat movie mind ya they
defeat Malekith and as the convergence
closes two more RAF pilots return kind
of reflecting Odin's two birds that
always come home those Ravens are
actually a big clue in the final scene
with Odin on the throne but Hugin Moonen
Matt owns pose is also slanted casual
unlike his normal posture but exactly
how Loki always sits on the throne
Loki's swap also explains why he doesn't
take me all near here and why he tells
Thor to go back to Midgard now the first
post-credit scene sets up the guardians
of the galaxy the scene was actually
directed by James Gunn Volstagg and
sniffed me the collector channel later
and Karina and among the collections
behind them is a Rayner one of the alien
species to show up in guardians and this
is Neptune that originally was gonna
contain Adam warlock though the
Guardians vol.2 post-credits scene
retcon that with a golden cocoon also in
guardians one of this movie's Dark Elves
can be seen among the collections the
second post-credits scene shows Thor
returning for a smooch with Jane though
if you look closely this is not Natalie
Portman since she couldn't be on set
that day it was just man that movie
wasn't being directed with Eddie Jenkins
not drama
this woman is Chris Hemsworth's
real-life wife Elsa Pataky this was an
alternate reshot ending to the movie's
original ending which was recently
revealed in the Infinity Saga box set
showing Odin visiting Thor recovering on
earth followed by Jane and dumped in
Thor I had days to imagine our life
together
I couldn't my work my life's work is
here a NASCAR damn useless in terms of
Thor and Jane's story I would say it's a
much better ending and ending that type
would teach me more or less assumes to
be true in RAM I'm sorry to hear that
Jane dumps you she didn't dump me you
know dumped us mutual dumping but it's
also an ending in which Loki I guess
stayed dead because Loki would never
want Thor to return to Asgard to me the
false Jane Foster in this reshot ending
is another example of the cost of
mistakes throughout the dark world this
imposter reflects Thor's blindness to
the imposter sitting on his throne it's
a blindness that Thor will pay for with
an I in Ragnarok in this movie his
mistakes cost him his mother that is why
it is so rewarding an in-game to see
Thor return to free good and learn the
lesson the dark world deprived him of
endgame doesn't just redeem the Avengers
mistakes with the Infinity stones it
redeems the shortcomings of this whole
cinematic universe and until we get
there the hero we're left rooting
forward is the imposter most successful
at exploiting others mistakes
the man who rises from prisoner to king
comment down below with your favorite
take away from rewatching Thor the dark
world and be sure to join our future
infinity saga watch lungs on discord by
becoming a patron at patreon.com such
new rock stars follow me on instagram
and twitter at EA vos follow new rock
stars and subscribe to new rock stars
for our next free watch where we'll see
why Thor and Odin aren't the only
grouchy pirates in the MCU last time I
trusted someone I
I
[Music]